[Music]
ABC is promising that the new American
Idol will be bigger bolder and better
than ever that's a bold statement so how
are they gonna do it well it might start
with bringing back the person arguably
greatest idol champ ever just this
morning while we asked Ryan Seacrest
what he knows what do you make of the
rumors that Kelly Clarkson may become a
judge on American Idol the og what do
you think of that I heard this same
rumors I think she was so well first
she's incredible
she was so remarkable and sincere and
lovely when she came on in the last
season's I think she would make a
fantastic job multiple sources tell et
that Idol producers are seriously
interested in hiring Kelly Clarkson as a
judge on the show when it relaunches so
will it happen well here are three
reasons why it could be a smart move for
both Kelly and Idol first the new
audition process a source close to
production tells us that instead of the
show's traditional grueling
cross-country audition tour this time
around
auditions could be held at Disneyland
and Disney World it would be mom
friendly for Kelly who has a 12 month
old son Remi and a 2 year old daughter
rivero's at home second Kelly's got the
experience Kelly Clarkson Clarkson won
idols first season and as Ryan mentioned
was a guest judge on the last she was
also an advisor on the boys and a mentor
on the 2012 singing competition duet and
three Kelly loves the collaboration the
singing shows were like the new way of
artist development which I'm proof of
other Idol alums who could be in the
running include Adam Lambert hot is a
ghost town and Kellie Pickler would you
ever want to come back as a judge I
would love to I will Ron's job watch out
and speaking of Ryan as hosts well this
morning he said he's up for the job no I
love the show so we'll see
last week he relocated to New York to
co-host live with Kelly and Ryan today
they were pleased the Grammys were
returning to New York one less red one
run red carpet has come to New York and
we just move American Idol
got to do it I get to do it
no you know that's gonna happen I'm done
it's probably a range on totally set it
up for that
[Music]
you